si vous avez regardé la vidéo précédente
vous savez maintenant quoi faire si vous
vous trouvez face à une personne
inconsciente et qui respire mais si vous
tombez sur quelqu'un de conscients et
qu'ils étouffent
vous faites quoi on va voir ça tout de
suite doug grose cécilia reyes gregory
house michaela quinn derek shepherd
elliot reid
quel est leur secret pour être si sexy
il sauve des vies j'avais fait une bonne
raison d' apprendre à sauver des vies
l'autre raison c'est apprendre à sauver
des vies ça peut sauver les vies
imaginez applaudi siroter un cocktail
dans une soirée chic quand soudain dans
l'assistance un individu avale son cake
aux olives de travers on appelle ça
faire une fausse route
son morceau de cake aux olives au lieu
de prendre la direction de l'estomac en
passant par le zoo fages
il s'est dirigé vers les poumons via la
trachée et il sait qu on sait là et le
pauvre où se mêlent a étouffé au milieu
des conduites qui fuit un peu l'ambiance
on va pas se le cacher mais procédons à
une reconstitution de la scène avec
notre mannequin de secourisme
olala je suis actuellement en train de
m'étouffer avec du cake aux olives
non en réalité le pauvre bougre en
question s'il est en train de s'étouffer
il peut pas parler il peut pas non plus
tous et il peut pas non plus respirer
parce que pour faire tout ça il faut de
l'air et que là pour le coup baiia du
cake aux olives campêche l'art de passer
c'est le principe de l'étouffement dans
ces cas là il faut tenter de faire
sortir le morceau cake aux olives en
pratiquant ce qu'on appelle la méthode
de heimlich du nom du médecin américain
qui l'a mise au point mais avant tout il
faut demander à quelqu'un de prévenir le
samu au 15 parce que votre camarade là
il est en danger devant avant de
commencer pencher le convive en avant
soutenez le haut niveau de la poitrine
avec une main et envoyé le mi5 grande
claque entre les omoplates avec le plat
de l'otm en cl cake aux olives est sorti
le convive se met à tousser
par contre s'il est toujours là où ils
devraient pas il faut passer aux choses
sérieuses placez vous derrière votre
camarade qui est en train de s'étouffer
passer vos bras sous ses aisselles
mettez votre point entre son nombril et
son sternum appuyer votre haute main à
plat par dessus serré bien fort et tiré
d'un coup sec vers vous et vers le haut
dans la vraie vie ce sera moins gênant
et quelqu'un d'habitué promis l'idée
c'est faire pression sur les poumons
pour que l'air comprimé face jaillir le
morceau cake comme un bouchon de
champagne vérifier régulièrement si le
morceau est pas ressortie ou s'il est
pas remonter dans la bouche et tant
qu'il est coincé recommencer les mêmes
manipulations jusqu'à ce que les secours
arrivent cinq grands claques dans le dos
5on pression abdominale
jusqu'à ce que sa soeur
attends t'es sur que c'est pas sortir il
faut réglementer à tort mais tu parles à
n'est ce pas tout seul je suis fière si
tu pouvais juste arrêter claques dans le
dos ce serait parfait
quand le morceau quelques de lits fini
par sortir asseyez la victime restée
avec elle
surveillez la et rassurer la en
attendant l'arrivée des secours
d'ailleurs si personne les a encore
rappelé c'est le moment de le faire
pareil si vous avez un doute appeler le
ils vous diront quoi faire attention si
ça fonctionne pas le convive va finir
par perdre connaissance
dans ce cas-là installé le doucement au
sol et commencé un massage cardiaque
vous savez pas comment faire non plus on
verra ça dans une prochaine vidéo à
dernière chose la méthode de heimlich ça
marche avec tous les corps étrangers
injuste mais qu'à cause de vive voix la
dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau geste
qui sauve abonnez vous pour pas rater ça
d'ici là éviter les ennuis
prenez soin des autres et de vous-même
et portez vous bien